Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain an American comedy film
called “Billy Madison”.
Watch out and take care!
Billy Madison is a spoiled 27-year-old man-child.
All he does is drink, play silly pranks with his
friends, and stare at nude magazines for hours.
He hasn’t grown a day since middle school,
much to his father Brian’s annoyance. Brian is the
founder of one of the largest chain of restaurants
in the US. He always had the wish
to pass down his fortune to his son,
but because of Billy’s lifestyle, he is rethinking
the decision. One day, Brain invites his business
associates for dinner at his house. Two of the
guests at the dinner are the company’s executive
vice president Eric and operations manager Carl.
Eric and Carl are close to Brain and help him make
all the important decisions about the company.
Brian wants to officially announce his retirement
but Billy interrupts him every time he starts to
talk. Eric doesn’t like Billy and does everything
he can to keep him childish so he wouldn’t be
appointed as the chairman of the company. He makes
faces at Billy, making him yell gibberish. In the
end, Brian yells at Billy to get out. Following
that, he goes out with his friends to a fast-food
restaurant. As usual, they talk like kids and
prank older people. Back in the mansion, Eric lays
down all the childish things that Billy has said
and done and convinces Brian he isn’t eligible to
take over the business. Carl, on the other hand,
claims that there is still hope for Billy but Eric
dismisses him. In reality, he wants to be promoted
as the president, so he is doing everything in
his power to remove his biggest competition.
Later at night, Brian calls Billy to his study
room to inform him of something big. He reveals
that he has decided to hand the business over
to Eric who he thinks is the most competent
of being a president. Billy is in shock because
his father has never denied to give him something,
let alone their family business. He argues that
Eric is cruel and uncaring but Brian is adamant
about his decision. He reveals that back when
Billy was in high school, he had bribed the
high school teachers to give him passing grades.
Not just that but every grade Billy ever passed
was because Brian somehow bribed the teacher.
Including the second grade where he spelled
Back as B-a-k and still passed. Since Billy
isn’t even a high school graduate, there is
no room for him to go against the decision.
Desperate to be heard, Billy proposes a deal
to his father. He promises to study in each
grade of school for two weeks and pass them all.
If he manages to do so, Brian will be sure of his
worthiness and hand the company to him. But if he
doesn’t, Eric will be named the president. Brian
likes the idea and makes some calls to get his son
into the first grade. The next day, the housemaid
Juanita makes Billy a lunch box and sends him
off to catch the school bus. He waits for it
but the bus passes by him without stopping.
When he reaches the school with his father, the
first person he sees is the third-grade teacher,
Veronica. She recognizes Billy as the spoiled
rich kid and instantly dislikes him. Following
the brief encounter, Billy goes to his
class and meets his new little friends.
He gets along with them pretty quickly because
even though he is older, his personality is not
different from theirs. They listen to stories,
play dodgeball, sleep during naptime, and do
the regular things that first graders do.
After school, a kid's mother comes to pick him up
and flirts with Billy. She is even more intrigued
when her son informs her that he is his classmate.
The next two weeks are fun for Billy. He
makes friends with everyone in the class
and is well-liked by his teacher Miss Lippy.
Although he sometimes accidentally eats glue,
fights with the kids about video games, and
has problems using the children’s urinals,
he is overall happy. After drawing a blue duck on
a drawing test, he passes first grade and throws
a huge graduation party for his friends. The
party has a pinata stuffed with Rolex watches and
expensive chocolates. His father, who had no faith
in Billy, is pleasantly surprised that he passed.
The only person not pleased about him passing
the grade is Eric. He has even appointed the
school’s janitor to keep an eye on Billy.
The second grade is more difficult than he had
thought, especially because of the spelling
tests. Billy goes against a little girl
in a spelling competition which he wins after
spelling the word “couch” correctly. Because
of the win, he passes third grade and throws
an even bigger party. He invites all of his
friends and plays with them on water slides.
Eric is also at the party and is planning to
do something big to make Billy fail.
The second grade is more difficult than he
had thought, especially because of the spelling
tests. Billy goes against a little girl in a
spelling competition which he wins after spelling
the word “couch” correctly. Because of the win,
he passes third grade and throws an even
bigger party. He invites all of his friends
and plays with them on water slides. Eric
is also at the party and is planning to
do something big to make Billy fail.
Finally, in the third grade, Veronica turns
out to be his teacher. Although she picks on him
and doesn’t really like him, Billy is motivated to
go to school just to see her. He creates trouble
in her class simply to be noticed, making it clear
that he likes her. One day, she finds him drawing
pictures of a half-naked girl in his notebook.
To teach him a lesson, she asks him to write a
few words on the board in cursive handwriting.
He does pretty well for the first few words, but
cannot seem to write the letter “z” correctly.
Veronica makes fun of him in front of the
entire class and humiliates him. Billy bursts
out shouting that he hates all of them and runs
home. The next morning, he pretends to be sick
so he wouldn’t have to go to school again. But
maid Juanita tells him that he will have to help
her shave her armpit if he stays home. Billy
reluctantly goes to school, not wanting to face
Veronica again. To his luck, she calls in sick
that very day. In her place, the principal of
the school, Mr. Anderson takes the class. During
recess, Billy receives several cards since it is
also valentine’s day. He is the coolest guy
in the class and is liked by many girls.
After school, Billy and his third-grade friend
Ernie hang out at his house. Billy misses Veronica
and asks Ernie to call her to see if she likes him
too. Earnie talks to her normally before asking
her if she would date anyone from their class.
Veronica calls Billy immature and ends the phone
call. The next day is the school field trip. On
their way to the location, some guys dare Billy
to touch Veronica’s chest. He happily accepts
the challenge and pretends to fall on top of her.
Veronica, on the other hand, playfully calls
him out for it as the kids laugh at him.
Later, Billy apologizes to her for what happened
and she forgives him. Then, he notices Ernie
standing alone in a corner and finds out that he
has wet his pants. To help his friend, Billy also
wets his crotch and claims that peeing yourself
is cool. All the children follow his lead and wet
their pants one after another. After seeing him
help Earnie, Veronica starts to like Billy.
In the following scene, Billy throws a third
party on passing the third grade. This one is
even bigger than the former two parties combined.
Kids run around the huge weather park that he has
arranged in front of his mansion. Veronica also
comes to the party and gives him snack packs as
a graduation gift. Billy shows her around as they
talk about different things. They eventually end
up inside a tent and are about to kiss when
Carl interrupts them. He warns Billy of Eric
who is planning something for his downfall. Billy
thanks him for the warning but doesn’t think much
of it. Starting that day, he studies hard and
passes the next four grades without any problem.
It has been a while since he met Veronica, so he
kisses her picture when he misses her. He is still
best friends with the third-grade students and
hangs out with them during the lunch break. They
often invite him to play soccer but the more he is
promoted to upper grades, the busier he gets.
When he passes the eighth grade, he organizes
yet another party to celebrate his entry to high
school. The school’s principal, Mr. Anderson meets
Eric in private during the party. Eric has done
some digging and found out about Anderson’s double
life. It turns out that he used to be a wrestler
who accidentally killed a man by sitting on him
for too long. If people find out about this,
he will lose his job as the principal. Eric takes
advantage of his situation and blackmails him.
He wants Anderson to spread a rumor that Billy
bribed him to pass the tests. With no other way
out, Mr. Anderson agrees to lie. The next day
is Billy’s first day at high school. The last
time he was in high school, Billy was one of the
popular guys. He had thought that it would be the
same this time around as well, but in contrast, no
one pays attention to him. During chemistry class,
he makes obnoxious jokes about the teacher but no
one laughs. A girl even asks him to not talk to
her because he is a loser and she doesn’t want to
be made fun of. One of the cool kids drops curry
on top of his head. Billy misses his third-grader
friends and goes to meet them during recess.
When asked about high school, he
lies and claims that everyone is
nice to him and he is having a great time.
At home, he realizes that when he was popular,
he also bullied the introverted kids. He calls
one of them named Danny and apologizes to him.
While on the phone, Danny simply forgives him
but after the call, he crosses out Billy’s name
from the “people to kill” list. Later that day,
principal Andrews publicly announces that he
was bribed by Billy to give him passing grades. A
disappointed Brian hands over the company to Eric
and doesn’t believe Billy when he tries to
explain himself. Billy loses all hope and
returns to his old lifestyle; partying all
the time and pranking people. Veronica knows
that he worked hard for the grades, hence she
picks him up one day and beats him brutally,
trying to motivate him to not give up without
a fight. Meanwhile, Billy’s third-grade friends
protest outside the principal’s house, making him
come clean about Billy’s grade and his lies.
After finding out the truth, Brian is ready to
give his son a second chance to continue high
school. However, Eric protests and claims
that since Billy didn’t complete the ninth
grade in two weeks, he isn’t eligible for the
company’s presidency. When Brian still doesn’t
side with him, Eric threatens to sue him. Billy
challenges him to an academic decathlon to finally
settle their feud with the winner
getting to take over the business.
The next Friday, they gather at school for the
competition. While Eric wins the math test,
Billy does great in the pie cooking competition.
Similarly, both of them win in some tests and
lose in others. By the end of it, Billy is
winning by a single point. The next day,
everyone gathers at the auditorium for the final
round that will determine the winner. Billy is
asked a question about the industrial revolution
and replies with a completely idiotic answer.
Then, Eric is asked a question regarding business
ethics. Eric being an unethical businessman has
no answer to the question. On realizing that he is
about to lose, he brings out a revolver, ready to
shoot Billy dead. He is saved when Anderson,
in his wrestling gear, tackles Eric. After
recovering from the attack, he attempts to shoot
Veronica, but before he can, he is shot by Danny,
whom Billy apologized to earlier for bullying.
In the following scene, Billy is at his graduation
ceremony. He announces that he wants to pass the
responsibility of his father’s business onto Carl,
who is more deserving than him. Billy also
reveals that he plans to attend college
in order to become a teacher. In the last scene,
we see Eric, walking away from the ceremony in
crutches while the others celebrate.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.